thanks for being with us America this is
your show angie is with us in Charlotte
North Carolina ing how are you I'm good
thank you thank you for taking my call
and giving me the opportunity to ask you
a question my question is we our own
baby step three and the last thing we
have for our debt is our house and I
have I have a few lingering old hospital
bills then you're not on maybe step
three well that's technically no I'm
trying to work that out there my husband
tells me that you say we should only pay
25 cents per dollar and I'm trying to
work with the the debtors to pay them I
only have one of them who are willing to
drop it at all and they're willing to
take off 40% and I'm only looking at a
total of about $3,800 so I don't know if
we should do that my husband tells me
know that you say that we should be able
to work it out with them to get it 25
cents per dollar and I have been working
with a bowel probably also old are the
debts they're about four years old are
you paying payments on them no we only
literally just started getting our like
bills and life together within the last
year so good for you all right
3,800 bucks and what's your household
income monthly it's about 6500 and our
debt are our allowances that we pay out
in food and bills and things like that's
about 3700 country okay I would take the
40% one how big one is that about $2,000
okay so that gets what half of it gone
right yes yeah and then just get in
writing the actual balance on the others
and just pay them I will see that was
gonna be my other question they refused
to do that then they get my here then
they get my money as they're playing you
and they're gonna come back for more
late fees and interest on top of what
they what you think you owe I got you so
okay
my husband were having he said no if he
wants to he wants to get all involved in
this it probably would be helpful okay
because I want him to get nasty with
them okay you have got to be kidding me
do you idiots want money or not if you
want money I'm standing here with money
but I have to have it in writing or I'm
not giving you a dime because I think
you're lying because your mouth is
moving okay because literally the guy
tells me he goes well we do not send out
letters we con send out emails we don't
care if you pay your bill or not because
it's on your credit it's your debt
and I'm thinking okay well consciously I
feel bad owing this money you know I'm
like I'm good we've changed you know
what I don't care I don't care if I pay
it either let me talk to your supervisor
because you're too stupid to talk to
okay this is how I mean you're not
dealing with intelligent life you're
talking to a collector who just told you
he doesn't care if you pay your bill
horse crap yeah you know dumb and just
say it you know just that that's a dumb
but statement do you think I'm gonna
fall for that let me talk to your
supervisor you're too stupid to work
this out a simple email from one of you
morons and I will send you a check and
you'll have this cleared up and I'll
have it cleared up isn't it your job to
collect the bill are you too stupid and
trifling to do your job you I'm sorry
people that are listening out there that
are nice people they don't understand
but you've not been dealing with
intelligent life the people you're
talking to his parents are cousins right
well obviously but hey thank you on that
and I want to say one more thing and
that other thing is that literally in
the last year that we've started doing
this like things have done such 150
degree turn around for us everything
like we just we appreciate the program
and it's working so well for us thank
you thank you very much listen dude look
at this conversation as a game so the
stuff that I'm doing right there it's
psychological warfare they're just
messing with you and here's the problem
if you send them a $250 check on a four
year old medical bill that you think is
doing
fifty dollars they're gonna send you a
bill for another two hundred and eight
dollars in late fees okay if you don't
have it in writing that this is the
actual balance gotcha okay I will do
that and not pay them until I get a
letter
yeah and just you know went in and call
them once a month and go I say you
idiots ready for money okay just start
the conversation that way because
everybody I've talked to over there's a
fool so far are you a fool you work
there you must be a fool because
everybody else that works there's a fool
so just just mess with them because
that's what they're doing with you and
I'm telling you they're playing you and
you will you will pull the thread on
this sweater forever if you don't get it
in writing and time down you can tell
they're lying if their mouth is moving